à quelques heures du réveillon du nouvel
an christophe castaner fait le point sur
le dispositif de sécurité accompagné de
laurent nunez secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur 140 2100 139
personnes seront mobilisées ce soir la
nuit de la saint sylvestre est l'une des
plus meurtrières sur les routes ce soir
si rien n'est fait et si l'on en suit la
statistique
hélas macabre des accidents de la route
près de 20 personnes vont mourir sur les
routes en france
j'en appelle vraiment à cette réflexion
ce verre de trop vaut-il la peine d'être
but je pense au décès je pense à ces
accidents graves dont on garde des
séquelles des traces tout au long de la
vie et je le dis c'est une demande que
nous avons fait aux forces de
gendarmerie aux policiers aussi d'être
présent sur le bord des routes pour
faire des contrôles sur le département
le chef de la gendarmerie des yvelines
informe qu'un tiers de ses effectifs
sont engagés ce soir soit 227 militaire
renforcée au besoin par 62 autres
militaires mobilisables sous deux heures
en cas d'urgence il ya les comportements
individuels qui mélange la fête avec la
violence est là aussi nous serons
mobilisés sur le terrain nous
connaissons des risques hélas normaux
notamment en matière de risque
terroriste est donc là aussi l'ensemble
de nos services sont mobilisés
nous connaissons une situation qui n'est
pas de tension anormal mais sur laquelle
nous devons faire face
le ministre de l'intérieur et le
secrétaire d'état se sont ensuite rendus
au centre d'incendié et de secours de
bois d'arcy et enfin au commissariat de
plaisir